now after a hearing someone who was
pretty skeptical shall we say about the
merits of HS - we can listen to someone
with a different take her to law
Barclays and that's the director of the
northern powerhouse partnership henry
morrison who joins us now from Ilkley in
yorkshire thank you very much for being
on the program starting off with HS
Laurie how what do you make of law
Barclays concerned about this high-speed
rail link I mean I sat and talked to
Lord Barclays along with a number of the
other panel members when they first
started their review and what always
concerns me when I listen to somebody
talking a programme saying things that
they've said before is that obviously he
was supposed to take part in a an
independent process to look at the
project and he seems to have pretty much
exactly the same views as when I first
met him and so I mean this sounds like
the the views of someone who's always
been a skeptic about chess to simply
making the same points they've made
before and although I actually do agree
with Tony about the importance of those
connections across the north those
commuter connections for instance
between cities like Leeds and Manchester
as Boris Johnson has promised to improve
with a new line I don't accept the
premise of his argument that it's a
choice between those improvements and
better connectivity to cities like for
instance Birmingham to Leeds or or from
say Sheffield to London which is
actually quite a tortuous journey to be
honest currently it's not the easiest
part of the rail network traverse so
what I would say in response to some of
Tony's claims I think his his numbers on
the the BCR he accused the government
and others of misleading Parliament
which i think is is wrong but he also
gets the numbers wrong so in our
evidence which we submitted to the
Ochopee process from an independent
panel of northern experts and leaders
who did all agree on their final report
and like unlike Tony with with the ochre
V review and we submitted figures
actually showed that the BCR that's the
cost-benefit number significantly
underestimates the benefits for instance
of HS 2 alongside rebalance the economy
through wider northern powerhouse
investments and this is also in only a
week since we saw leaks the government's
going to revise the Green Book anyway
because it doesn't advantage the north
and the Midlands priorities enough and
so you've got Tony on your program
arguing that the green book and the DFT
appraisal process is too generous to hs2
when actually all of government policies
that the benefits of major projects like
that of hs2 or northern powerhouse rail
so the north are being systematically
undervalued so I think I think it's a
nice way name the same arguments he's
always made and he doesn't seem to have
listened to any of the evidence that we
and others have presented him with at
the same time they we're talking about
an exorbitant amount of money here and
the costs have spiraled even if there is
a debate about exactly how much hs2 is
going to cost and I guess what labaki
would argue is he's not saying that you
know in an ideal world would be great to
have a high-speed rail link plus
connections to cities and towns in the
north of England but you're saying is
this the best way to spend each eight
billion pounds so I mean we would argue
that it is and the reality for that is
that there is no other way to underpin
rebalance into British economy so you do
need connections for instance from
cities like Birmingham to leads and more
capacity to get down to London if you're
going to continue to rebalance the
economy and what the damage is that
there isn't an alternative that adds up
so he's talked in great detail on your
program about these conventional
upgrades well there is no plan for that
that stacks up and actually when you do
try and upgrade the West Coast Main Line
it still costs billions and billions
we've tried to do it before a decade ago
we had to shut it every weekend for
years and I think many Northerners who
experienced the upgrades the West Coast
Main Line for what were significant
benefits would be really quite upset if
we spent a similar round money to get
water then be a small amount of benefits
but actually if you built a
purpose-built new line you would also
unlock the West Coast Main Line for
freight and commuter services because
the particular irony of what Lord
Barclays saying on your program today is
actually around cities like Sheffield
and Manchester HS who unlocks critical
commuter infrastructure for instance to
get to places like Stockport big
commuter town for Manchester to get from
Chesterfield which is really nearby to
Sheffield but very congested bit of rail
line from Chesterfield Sheffield
actually local commuters are some the
biggest beneficiaries make Chester - and
so if you want to improve the lives for
northern commuters then you do need more
capacity in the rail network actually HS
- by unlocking the existing capacity
makes a huge contribution to that and
again it sounds disingenuous for Tony
not to accept that in his remarks this
morning we're running out of time
there's a couple of other thing
I'm keen to talk about it widely you of
course have been you know banging the
drum for more investment in the north of
England for some years now but it feels
after the election there has been almost
a renewed focus on the north of England
and also the Midlands after those
dramatic results we saw in those areas
I wonder if any part of me thinks that
they've heard you've heard this all
before or do you really believe for us
Johnson when he says that he wants to
prioritize investment in these northern
communities I think that the Prime
Minister's commitment is genuine and I
think there are those around the cabinet
table like Jake berry and Ritchie sunic
who genuinely believe in for instance
projects like northern powerhouse rail
but also wider initiatives for instance
to rebalance spending in research and
development you've got those like the
science Minister for instance who aren't
around the cabin table but are very much
kind of real supporters of this I think
the point is that people need to get
behind those like the science minister
or or really sunic at the Treasury to
help them to deliver these commitments
in time for the budget I know that
there's been lots of people who said
that the commitment to this and the
government nine are genuine I'm prepared
to give the Prime Minister the benefit
of the doubt but he is going to have to
make sure he really does deliver because
the promise was made five years ago by
George Osborne in that northern power
speech that will rebalance the British
economy that would have huge benefits an
additional trillion of economic value by
2050
but this government after Teresa Mae's
lackluster approach has really got to
rust the nettle because otherwise those
commitments that help them win the blue
wall seats might might lead to them
losing them talking about that just
briefly in a Sunday Times this morning a
civil servant who used to run the
northern northern powerhouse project and
Nicola headland said our ideas were
allowed to wither and die we kept
knocking on the door but nobody was
listening including number 10 the
machinery of Whitehall doesn't work for
the regions is that true I think we do
need to have a different institutional
settlement and I think we need to take
the powers and responsibilities out of
Whitehall I'd go even further then
Nicola does in that piece in her
comments to the Sunday Times and I would
say that we actually need to do is take
spending decisions around infrastructure
and transport out of London completely
and bring them back to our northern
leaders like that option the mayor of
the Tees Valley Andy Burnham
and Steve Rotherham the the mayor's in
the Northwest on the labor side
government needs to trust those mayor's
create more elected mayor's but also
give more powers to transport the north
of that pan northern level because the
people I do trust to make those
decisions and get stuff done are our
mares and our civic leaders work across
the north as long as we rely on the
generosity of a particular civil servant
or having the right people around the
cabinet table that's not good enough the
north of England we need to take power
permanently from Whitehall and I think
that's the only way we're ever going to
get real progress